welcome everybody to a bit
of treat what i have to check out today
is the dgx station a 180 gigabytes which
is the latest super computer slash
data center at home straight gpu power
insanity from nvidia
like a workstation it can fit under a
desk and plug into a regular home wall
outlet but unlike a workstation has 320
gigabytes of gpu memory
and is cooled with refrigerant even
getting the machine out of the box is
pretty well engineered where
after you've removed the top of the box
a ramp folds out and then there's a door
to the side of the box that swings
open since the dgx station has
wheels you quite literally just roll it
out from there
so the machine itself has a sort of
matte gold finish with
some mirror trimming and then along the
top and the back you've got this like
really
interesting like solid breathable
mesh and at the top it is for the
exhaust
but along the back there's more of it
this appears to just be for show
because underneath it it's completely
solid but the stuff on the top
actually it does breathe and this is
where the machine exhausts
so while we're looking at the back for
the ports that we have we've got a
couple of usb
2 10 gigabit ethernets usb type c and
vga on the motherboard you can also see
this like bright yellow sticker that's
actually covering yet another
ethernet port and that's for the bmc
remote management because
again this is basically a data science
server
finally we can see down below we've got
four mini display port
ports which are actually part of a
dedicated dgx display card so while i
imagine many people are going to be
using this
like a server and mainly using like
shell access you
can indeed use it like a workstation
okay cool
what's inside so to get inside the
station there's two buttons on the back
you just push the button on the side
that you want to open and that pops out
the door
and you just lift away the door
once inside on the motherboard side you
can see there's a clear
plastic shroud that's covering
everything and we can just pull that out
so we can see everything a little more
clearly
and what we see is truly beautiful there
is
so much goodness here so the cpu is a 64
core 128 thread
amd epic sitting on top of that
we get our first glance at the cooling
which is obviously not air it's not
water
it's refrigerant it doesn't get any
better than that
i guess unless you had like liquid
nitrogen but this is zero maintenance so
i'll say that wins there's also eight
ram sticks here each of which
is a whopping 64 gigabytes so that adds
up to
512 gigabytes of memory near the
motherboard
battery underneath some heat shielding
you've got a two terabyte m.2
boot drive uh this is for your operating
system and then over to the right
we've got um some covering there but you
can also see
there's like two little slots you can
pull those out one of those is empty the
other one has
a 7.68 terabyte ssd
up towards the top we can see three
rather large exhaust fans which of
course makes us then wonder
hey what's up there since that's where
the textured breathable sort of mesh
pattern is so as a total shocking
surprise i'm sure none of you saw this
coming
what is up there is it's a giant
radiator and while i can't show the
entire cooling system this
is a rendering of it which i think is
pretty cool
and while the cpu i'm sure enjoys all of
this cooling it's
really here for the gpus so you can see
here on the motherboard side where
things are connecting to the pcie 4.0
slots of the motherboard via these sort
of like paddle cards
these cards aren't the actual gpus
so on the other side of the machine
these
are the gpus and the refrigerant cooling
plates on top
all connected together via a 4-way hdx
gpu board and this system is what
connects to the motherboard via the
cables that you saw on the other side to
those paddle cards
into the pcie 4.0 slots for
instructions each of these
four gpus is it's an a 180 gigabyte card
so all together this is 320 gigabytes
of gpu memory these are a100 so these
are the
latest and greatest ampere gpus which
are
both the fastest gpus in existence right
now
that at least we're aware of and this is
more memory per card again than
any other gpu out there so this is
this is just insane and to think that
all of these things come together
into a single system that is still
even capable of plugging into a 120 volt
home outlet which basically limits you
to 1500 watts
um that's insane
it's just insane so let's plug in our
super data science server computer gpu
power house
and see how it actually performs so
before we get too deep into the weeds
with testing i should note that while
yes we're comparing gpus here we're also
kind of comparing the systems that
house those gpus at some point it would
be awesome to compare a couple of
a100s directly to a couple rtx 8000s via
the same exact system for a truly fair
comparison but right now this is this is
what i've got i can't
i can't take those a100s out of the dgx
system and i can't easily put
two more cards into the uh djx system
itself so
take these results with a little bit of
wiggle broom if you're thinking of
comparing
you know just gpus here because
software hardware and other factors can
just cause
you know 10 15 plus percent difference
in performance easily and i've seen i've
seen it be even
even more than that so also i think the
card that you'd want to compare to the
a100 is the
v100 i don't have a v100 and so i just
i'm going to be using the rtx8000 the
rtx 8000 is
i would argue very competitive to the
v100 at least in terms of single
precision performance so
it should be a fairly good good battle
between between cards in terms of
actual um you know tf32
teraflops
the rtx 8000 i believe edges out the the
uh the v100 so anyways what are we going
to test we're going to test a
transformer model it's going to be the
transformer big
from the tensor to tensor library this
is six
layers of 16 attention heads and a layer
size of
1024 uh we're also going to be using a
batch size of 1024 per card this should
keep both cards relatively happy the rtx
8000 can take a batch size of up to
like 3000 before hitting memory issues
also just want to keep the gpu util down
and not
you know constantly pinging 100 because
that'll kind of hurt the results a bit
so what i'm trying to compare
here is just core speed you know how
much faster
are these cores because we already know
the the gpu memory is
like you know i don't know 1.8 x
whatever it is because the rtx 8000 has
48 gigs of memory per card and the
a100s here have 80. there's also a 40
gig version for the
a100 so we already know it has way more
memory but i'm curious about
processing speed so what we have here is
the
benchmarks across a single gpus
two gpus and then on the a100 for gpus
the idea here is to show the exact same
uh model the same batch size all of that
and just kind of compare
the a100s in their respective machine
to the rtx 8000 again in their
respective machines so
these gpus might not be exactly this
much different from each other if they
were in the same machine but it's still
worthy
uh worthy comparison so to begin let's
look at the
one gpu test so again just for clarity
this is a single gpu running that
transformer model
for 10 000 steps at a batch size of 1024
it is per gpu but it's just one gpu here
so uh what couple of things first of all
this is relative mode so they did the
exact same number of steps it's just
that this top one here this is the
a100 steps per second and this is the
box
steps per second we can see the entirety
of that benchmark
took 33 minutes and 39 seconds for the
box machine
and it took 12 minutes and 42 seconds
for the a100
so the a100 uh we'll just grab a spot
for steps did
we'll call it 14 steps a second and the
box machine did five steps per second
also just for clarity too these like
kind of
jaggedy step downs this is when the
model was saved
the checkpoint and then also eval was
run so just again for clarity i can
switch over to
step mode and again you can see that
they both did the same number of steps
and they save at the exact same
kind of point to every thousand steps
essentially so
coming back into relative mode yeah so
we can see that basically five steps per
second for the box and 14 for the a100
that is a considerable difference that's
2.8 times faster for the a100 on the
exact same model
um that's that's really impressive
um you know i would i would think that
was some sort of trickery or marketing
marketing uh specific test that would
give you that kind of performance but
no it appears that that is truly the the
uh
increased performance over the rtx 8000
which is already
a very fast gpu so very impressive there
and then we don't need to look at
learning rate uh
we can come check loss real quick and
again it might look like oh the a100
actually
learns stuff faster but i mean it does
in time but as far as steps are
concerned you can see that basically
they reach the exact same conclusion
so now what we can do is check out the
two gpu situation so if we
i think first just so i don't screw
myself up i'm gonna untick the one gpus
and turn on just the two gpus
so in this case it is again the exact
same model
it's a thousand and twenty four batch
per gpu so effectively at 2048 for the
actual model that's being trained
so again we can see a considerable
advantage to the a100 where
the uh box will say does 4.43
yeah four point somewhere between 4.4
and
4.5 steps per second and then the a100
is doing like 12.2
to 12.3 it looked like so um
again this is a 2.8 ish
x performance enhancement so
yeah so we we can see that that kind of
2.8 x performance
on this very specific model and very
specific setting
still is is holding true the other
interesting aspect
can be to compare the one gpu versions
to the two gpu versions and in both
cases so like for example for the a100
it did 14 steps a second on one gpu and
then 12.2 on two gpus
and this is super common uh you you like
jumping up one more gpu or doubling your
gpus you you really can never
expect that you're going to see a 100
percent
improvement in performance uh in this
case we see
it's it's about 88 improvement and we
actually see that on both cards the box
and the a100
both see this like 88 uh improvement so
one gpu two gpu the dgx is 2.8 times
better
both gpu or both systems appear to scale
out the gpus
um to at least from one to two at an 80
per 88
uh efficiency i suppose i would call it
uh and then the final
thing that i would show is the four gpo
unfortunately
uh life is very hard for me and i'd only
have the two rtx 8000s i would be very
curious
uh to see the four gpu setup
uh from the rtx 8000
versus the four gpu setup on the a100
because
again the a100s aren't pcie cards in the
dgx station
they're these like sxm2 cards and then
they connect
over this hgx board and then it's that
board that's plugging into the pcie so i
would be curious like
when at what point does that board start
to make more sense because it has a lot
more
memory bandwidth uh to my understanding
than pcie
so possibly at the four gpu or eight gpu
or 16 gb
at some point i bet that starts to make
a whole lot of sense
um i doubt well first of all there is no
two gpu hdx board from nvidia
that i have seen i think they're all
four and eight or more
anyway so the ford gpu setup for the
a100 i don't have anything to compare it
to but the curiosity is still there is
it still an 88
efficiency and as we can see
the four and again this is four gpus
each of those four gpus has a batch size
of 1024 going into it
so what we see here is that indeed so in
this case let's say it's doing 10.7 ish
steps per second
again that's an 88 improvement over the
2 gpu setup so
it looks like every time you double gpus
it's 88
so it would be very curious to see does
that continue and what would happen
to the rtx 8000 could we
could we double the two gpus and make
that also an 88
improvement who knows we need lots of
gpus and lots of money to find out that
answer
but um at the end of the day we can
clearly see
that uh the a100 gpu is
unbelievably fast i i 2.8 x over the
previous what i would call the previous
fastest gpu like the v100 was fast
uh the rtx 8000 is just about as fast or
faster there is like the v100s which i
think just slightly
like maybe it has like .1 more teraflops
or something than the rtx 8000
so i mean these were like the best cards
and then for the a100 to come in and be
almost three times faster
that's that's truly truly insane
so lastly i want to talk about
temperatures and
power draw which basically you know go
hand in hand so first off
temperatures of these cards running for
these 10 000
steps so what we can see here is a
pretty substantial difference in
temperatures between these cards so the
rtx 8000 those are the two cards up top
and also for these tests the ambient
temperature in the room
uh at least started at 75 degrees
fahrenheit
later it does if if i left this run
like 24 7 the temperature becomes 78 to
79 fahrenheit
75 fahrenheit is 24 celsius for
all you non americans
so uh the periodic drops that you see
there again are just the saving of the
checkpoint
and evaluation so i do find it curious
that uh there are
some of these like larger drops on the
rtx cards not sure exactly what is
happening there
again many factors could be could be
causing that
and that's exactly why you would much
rather i think put these gpus in the
exact same system
regardless yeah you can see that the
a100 sat between 55 and 58 degrees
celsius
where the rtx 8000s were 75 to 85
celsius with one card
was noticeably hotter the reason for the
heat can be seen in this photo this is
the
box workstation and these are the rtx
8000s
it might appear that the photo is upside
down but actually the motherboard is
quote unquote upside down inside the box
workstation
so the reason for the heat for these
cards is as you can see they're just
stacked right on top of each other and
then connected via that envy link well
the in the photo the card that is on the
bottom the fan for that card the intake
is actually kind of at the top so it's
intaking as you can see a very small
portion of air and that air is actually
pretty hot from the card
that sits right on right above it so it
kind of gets the short end of the stick
so to speak
cooling wise and that's why it is so
much more hot
than the other card that has a little
bit of space there to
to actually suck in um better quality
air
um and then in the you know if you're
using water cooling
or to some extent you know warm air does
rise so the card on top is gonna rise
but with like
if you use like water cooling that's
probably not going to be such an issue
and then obviously if you're using
refrigerant like we are with the a100s
and the way that the a100s are kind of
situated and spread out it's just
it is a it's a better setup for keeping
the cards
essentially the same temperature as you
can see i mean they're much much closer
so next we can check actual power draw
i found this one to be pretty
interesting
again seeing how the rtx's
should you know they should have been
able to fit a much larger batch size
into memory
but we can see the rtx 8000s are
slurping up the full
250 watt tdp essentially whereas the
a100
sat at something like an average of i
don't know 175 watts so the
the rtx 8000's were still sucking full
power and that could also be
part of why they were getting so hot um
i don't think they would suck any more
power than they actually needed so maybe
uh even smaller batch size was required
i'm not sure
so while the gpu that runs in the 50s
celsius does sound like a dream it's not
quite fair because clearly we aren't
pushing these cards hard enough
um and the cooling system here is
designed with four
hot gpus in mind so uh if we want to
test that you know
what do we do well we can always load
gpt3 medium
into a batch size of 5120 per gpu
effectively having a batch size of
twenty thousand four hundred and eighty
and then i think we will make these
cards sweat a little bit
so uh first we will show the power draw
so it looks like
right now we're seeing a more reasonable
power draw the listed tdp
in for these cards in nvidia smi is 275
but it this chart here we are maxing out
these gpr's
gpus this chart here would suggest the
tdp
is more like maybe 250 or even 240 so
that is
kind of interesting but what about the
temperatures so here we can see the
temperatures range
you know in the 70s and if we take a
slightly closer look
we can see that this is kind of more in
line with temperatures that we would
expect and i think arguably hope for
with a machine that may very well be
expected to run
24 7 at full capacity so we're seeing a
range of anything from 70 to
this kind of peak temperature of 78
degrees celsius which is totally fine
within typical operating range
for sure and this is again with all four
gpus running at full tilt so i can't
imagine a more stressful
situation for the cooling so for my
overall impression of this uh
dgx a 180 gigabyte station
um i think i would sum it up with my
main
uh emotion towards it and that is
addicted the the power on this machine
is um it feels like an order of
magnitude
faster and it is an order of magnitude
faster than
the uh box workstation that i have and
that workstation is already
a high-end kind of top of the line
workstation
so for this to come in with a similar
form factor and i recognize it it
probably looks very large but
this is actually smaller than my main
computer is it's kind of like the size
of an atx
xl case or something plus the wheels
kind of make it sit up a little a little
taller but
actually it is it's not that large and
it's
basically like a data science server
so for it to be in this form factor is
is pretty staggering
uh to me also the gpus i mean these gpus
this is just like the next generation
and the next generation is
three times faster i mean well 2.8 but
close to three um
that is that's just mind-blowing to me i
mean what a step
a step to take and then obviously the 80
gigs of memory
uh per card is also just a massive step
so um just overall i mean the whole
thing is just kind of absurd i mean it's
so
powerful and that's why my expectation
is you know first off i know a lot of
people want to know
how much does it cost um to put it in
perspective
uh so this has four a 100 80 gigabyte
cards in it
and generally with these like data
center type cards you have kind of two
versions
one one will be like double the memory
and the other one is like half of the
memory right so
for the v100s for example you've got
your 16 gig and your 32 gig versions
the a100 you've got a 40 gig and an 80
gig version
so generally the cloud
version will be the smaller version so
the a100 if you rent an a100 in the
cloud it's going to be most likely a 40
gig
and the dgx stations come in either
160 gig or 320. so this one is the 320
because each card has 80 gigs of memory
but you can also get the 160
and that is the one that has the 40 gigs
so to put it in perspective if you
rented four a 100 40 gig
cards in the cloud for a year
that would be the cost of your dgx a100
160 gig
station so at the point of about a year
you could have bought uh something like
this so
that's kind of that should give you the
idea of the price i think no matter what
number i say people are going to lose
their minds it's a lot of money
but these are also high-end extremely
powerful cards again i wouldn't think of
this as
you can treat it like a workstation it's
the form factor
of a workstation but it is a data
science
or a data center kind of server type
of performance um and i think bang for
your buck it's it is definitely there
and then also obviously if you rent a
gpu after a year
uh you've got nothing versus after a
year you would still have this and this
is going to last you
this is going to be top of the line if
not the you know for sure high end
for five plus years so
um yeah and then obviously if you have
any
any sort of security concerns or privacy
concerns with what you're doing
uh data wise or you know whatever if
your models are proprietary or whatever
the case may be if you need it to be
not in the cloud then obviously you need
something
local so the other interesting thing
that i don't think i've brought up yet
on the ampere cards is the ampere cards
have this
mig technology and that stands for
multi-instance
gpu and what you can do with that
is essentially partition off um
each individual gpu into halves thirds
or
into sevens so potentially this machine
can serve up to 28
individuals so again it's more like a
server
uh than a workstation in that regard so
in in this multi-instance gpu it's not
just like a memory fraction you're
literally
partitioning off a section of that gpu
and that's like memory bandwidth memory
itself
processing like the actual cores um
all of that it gets partitioned away and
it's as if it's it's actually a mini gpu
so um so yeah you can serve uh
like this this would make sense in some
sort of like you know business
environment like i had a company
a team within a company or um
at like a university like research lab
that kind of stuff i think that's
probably where i kind of foresee
something like this being used but don't
get me wrong
as a single person you can use it and it
is very intoxicating to have this entire
thing to yourself but
um i don't know that that will be the
main use case but if you
can afford one then have at it it will
be very fun
[Music]
so um anyway yeah i mean i i can't
imagine this have gone going any other
way
i knew what the specs were before it
showed up so i kind of had an idea of
what to expect and unless the thing like
blew up or something i was going to
just fall in love with it so of course i
fell in love with it um
and it's been i've been running it
non-stop since i got it as soon as i
heard from nvidia that they were going
to send one
i started planning immediately what i
was going to do so there would be like
no down time so so yeah it's been uh
it's been very
very enjoyable so anyways uh that's all
uh if you've got questions comments
concerns whatever uh feel free to leave
those below i'll do my best to answer
them i won't have it for too much longer
but i definitely have
a few more videos uh that will almost
certainly feature
the dgx station most of what i've been
doing has been kind of chat bot training
and again like i've been able to do
like a year's worth of um r d and just
testing of different models in like the
month that i've had this
so that's that's incredible i mean
that's so
it's just been it's been a lot of fun
having that much power
um and and you really it's really there
i mean it's like three extra performance
i've got
nearly 4x that's somewhere between 3 and
4x the memory
um and then two times the the gpus
so yeah the the the the amount of
performance over that workstation has
just been
just staggering for me so anyways
um that's it like i said questions
comments whatever feel free to leave
them below if you've got questions on
the machine or whatever
let me know otherwise i will see you
guys
in another video
you